ja ein halbes jahr krieg in der ukraine
und wir wollen uns heute ansehen wie
rücksichtslos und wie brutal putin vor
geht um im lot im osten des landes
weiter boden gutzumachen erstmal gucken
wir uns das ganze anders ist die ukraine
ihr rechts haben wir den bombast und
nahezu die gesamten aktivitäten der
russischen armee konzentrieren sich
derzeit auf dieses gebiet nämlich auf
die region donetsk wo man nach der
eroberung von lohans versucht
vorzurücken sowohl nördlich der 2014
besetzten großstadt millionenstadt
donetsk als auch in richtung kramer
thorsten snow wiegands dort hat die
russische armee in den letzten tagen
weitere drei kleine dörfer und ihre
kontrolle gebracht und wie sie das macht
das können wir uns hier mal ansehen das
sind wirklich unfassbare aufnahm das
hier ist die stadt bisky die stadt pisco
frontstadt dieser 2014 gehalten wird von
der ukrainischen armee und wir sehen
hier aerosol waffen also thermo
bayerische explosionen die auf große
wohnhäuser entladen werden diese stadt
hatte er als 5600 einwohner davon ist
fast niemand mehr da aber die
ukrainische armee verhält das eben und
wir sehen was die russen versuchen das
sind wie gesagt thermo bayerische
explosionen die also den sauerstoff in
der luft nutzen um die explosionen noch
größer zu machen um 1 unter druck zu
erzeugen um ihnen diese häuser und wir
sehen das auch immer wieder zum einsturz
zu bringen das sind 56 gehstöcke
wohnhäuser wo eben die soldaten
versuchen ja die front zu halten und
russland kommt einfach nicht anders
voran deshalb setzt man diese waffen
einen das schlimmste das tatsächlich
schlimmste nicht atomare oder nicht
chemische potenzial was eben russland
hat und damit die ukraine eben nicht
zurückschießen können damit ihnen nicht
sagen können okay super wir haben euch
jetzt geordnet wir können jetzt auf euch
schießen deshalb nutzen die russen die
eroberten gebiete immer wieder als
menschliche schutzschilde die menschen
die dort sind und wir sehen dass hier
einmal ein bm 21
raketenwerfer der russischen armee der
hier 41 raketen am stück abschließt und
direkt davor ja wir sehen sie einen
kaffee koffein ja das ist ein café von
wo aus der hier schießt in der stadt
passe aber wir sehen wie eine rakete
nach der anderen dort abgeschossen wird
geht also in den himmel er versteckt
sich direkt neben dem café wenn die
ukraine dorthin zurück schießen und das
sind zivilisten übrig dann haben wir ein
großes problem auf der anderen seite
auch hier sehr sehr gut zu sehen der bm
21 werfer ein weiterer und hier eine
filiale der supermarktkette
in papas na also auch hier direkt zivile
infrastruktur da nehmen und wir haben
letzte woche gehört von der
menschenrechtsorganisation amnesty dass
die die ukraine beschuldigt dass sie
sich in der nähe von zivilen
objekten verteidigen gegen die russen
das ist hier die realität die russen
greifen angreifen das land an nicht nur
das land sondern auch die städte an von
zivilen infrastrukturen was versuchen
die ukraine dagegen ja sie versuchen was
sie können und sie versuchen sobald sich
die russen aus diesen bewohnten gegenden
ebenso ein bisschen bewegen und 30
herausbewegen
versuchen sie die panzer einzelne
anzugreifen um eben nicht diese große
zerstörungen in ihren eigenen städten
ihrer eigenen infrastruktur zu erzeugen
hier sehen wir
jetzt einmal ganz kurz hier hinten einen
russischen panzer der sich an der grenze
zwischen der region donetsk tief bewegt
und hier eine ukrainische jahr will ihn
rakete die auf ihn geschossen wird
lassen das ganze mehr laufen und wir
sehen dass dieser panzer dort eben ja
diesen rauch erzeugt weil ich eben da wo
im sommer lang bewegt und wie er jetzt
auch im motor teil gleich getroffen wird
von der ukrainischen rakete die sie ja
wenn den rakete kam aus den usa ist sehr
zielgerichtet und hat in diesen panzer
dort getroffen und interessanterweise
versucht der panzer dann aber noch ein
bisschen weiter zu fahren das heißt der
fahrer versucht irgendwie noch der weg
zu kommen aus dem ukrainischen feuer zu
kommen die drohne film das ganze und ist
nicht ganz klar warum der das macht ihr
versucht also weiter zu fahren
vielleicht etwas feuer zu löschen oder
ähnliches das klappt aber nicht und wir
sehen gleich immerhin wieder russische
sotschi glück hat und sich aus diesen
panzer verabschiedet müssen wir sie dann
heraus klettert und den brennenden
panzer zurücklässt das also hier szenen
von ukrainischen gegenangriffen auf
rosige einheiten die ihm nicht auf die
breite zerstörung sondern genau auf das
auf das militär material der russen
zählt und insofern die ukraine also
völlig andere taktiken weiterhin benutzt
wir schon oft gesagt qualität statt
quantität zielgerichtetheit stadt alles
plattmachen als die russische armee um
sich zu verteidigen